[音楽]
青木サの人生系哲学100回聞いたら豊か
になる話青木サの人生系哲学100回聞い
たら豊かになる話ということで今回はです
ね目的と目標の違いについて是非教えて
いただけますでしょう
[音楽]
かそうねま目とというのはま英語では
パーパスですよね目的ってままさに大常談
ですよね一度の人生2度ない人生どう
生きるかというようなどちらかというと
生きがいとかやりがいとか自分自身の存在
価値そういうところに焦点を当てたものが
本当に自分にとって大切なもの私は何を
求めているのか私にとって1番大切なもの
は何か私が本当に大切にしているものは
こういうのは目的ですよねでゴールって
いうのはそれを成し遂げるために今何を
いつまでにやり遂げなければならないのか
具体的にねま例えばですよ自分自身が将来
ま1つのま自分の業界で偉大なやっぱり
こう職業人として成功者になりたいという
風に思っているじゃあ成功とは何かね自分
の知っている人の中で最もモデルとする
業界の渋沢一さんのような人になりたいと
仮に思ったとじゃあ渋沢一さんて500の
会社を作り600の非営理組織を作ったと
いう偉人ですよね資本主義の父と言われる
人だよね日本のねそういう人に近づこうと
思ったらじゃ今何を遂げなきいけないのか
となったに今期売上ね例えば100億の
売上経常力20億それを正社員300人で
やろうっていうのは目標なんですよこれ
成し遂げないで売上1億ね利益が
1000万で社員も20人ぐらいにしか
ならないみたいな組織でこれ自体も目標
達成できなくてもう資金売りどうしようと
かて言って目的的っていうのはちょっと
やっぱりこういうずれる状態になりますよ
ねだから大事なことは将来なりたい姿と今
現在今年の課題は何かそして具体的に今期
売上いくらで利益がいくらで社員も何名に
するという具体的にするとこれは目標に
なるわけです目標を達成して目的を遂げる
そういう風に思ってもらといいと思います
ねでもこの目標と目的って決して分離し
てるものじゃないんですよ長期的なものと
短期的なものさらにはその先にある自系列
の中の最終的に自分がどんな人間になり
たいかというところから落とし込んで短期
中期長期の目標を設定して段階よって実現
をしていくそれが大切なことじゃないかと
思います一方でやっぱり目標にすごく焦点
が当たりすぎてしまうことってなんかある
のかなと思ったりするんですけどどうし
たらそのバランスよくどちらともこう
向き合っていけるの
かこれはね私が考えてそのアチーブメント
ピラミッドという概念ですよね1番下に
人生理念があり次が人生ビジョンがあり
目標があり計画があり日々の実践があると
ここに一貫性を通すと実は私の若い時って
目標から上の人生でしただマネとメダル
確かにプロセールスの世界でトップ
セールスにないトップマネージャーになっ
たでも幸せじゃなかったんですよだから
成し遂げても幸せじゃなかったでま29歳
の時にま私は人生を変える大きな天気が
あって目的に出会ったわけですよねだから
その目的から目標を設定し計画を立て日々
の実践によってそれを成就していくまこの
ピラミッドの一貫性を通す生き方ができる
ようになって私は充実感を得たんです
そして達成は当然通貨点なので達成してく
んだけど達成に生きるんじゃなくて目的に
生きる人生そういう人生に私は変わりまし
た納得してます